AARON WHEELER: My name
is Aaron Wheeler.
I'm a UX prototyper at Google.
At the end of 2011, I
participated in the Dart hackathon.
I thought it should be easy to
transfer my knowledge of
JavaScript to Dart, so I
started taking notes.
And my notes grew into a
spreadsheet, and then the
spreadsheet grew in my
hackathon entry.
I built a website in Dart that
ingests a Google spreadsheet
JSON feed and pretty prints
the results in an easy to
browse website.
Over the holidays, the idea
caught on with my friends
Marcin and Seth, who had
continued to contribute to the
spreadsheet, and thus
the website.
The momentum continued to grow,
the site received a
visual refresh, and the
comparisons were blessed by
the Dart team.
I'm excited that Dart
Synonym is really to
be shared with everyone.
I hope you find it useful.